I just feel I feel the Ludvig has young
legs that's all set anyway great to see
everyone right so where to begin so this
is this is joint work with a bunch of
awesome people and I think really
pushing on a lot of really interesting
empirical work and I think I'm not gonna
say that the talk will be
uncontroversial so if I say a thing that
makes you angry that's for me and if you
say anything that's like well that's
awesome that's from one of these fours
alright so I know this is works up on
deep learning I'd like to start with
machine learning that's why I talk about
machine learning and I want to talk
about kind of the conventional wisdom
that we give to our undergraduates
Jonathan here teaches hundreds of them
and so I hope I don't know how many of
these things you tell them one they're
like some how to have a good predictor
you have to balance bias and variance
alright and that you really should not
perfectly fit your training data that's
a no-no t something we definitely teach
them that in right yeah you have to oh
he already knows you don't the punch
line this is the sad part and we know
that high capacity models right wouldn't
have really big ones shouldn't
generalize that you got to keep them
small because if you you know said on
the first day trying to do
one-dimensional polynomial regression
right and optimize high precision non
convex optimization that's hard and I
think everybody in this room at this
point knows that none of these are true
right it's a it's weird right so we keep
all kind of come to the terms that none
of these things are true and yet we
teach in our undergraduate classes I'm
trying it's really hard to teach them
anything else to be honest nuance is
really difficult at the undergraduate
level especially when there are 700 of
them so I think that's a kind of
complicated thing but it is this weird
thing that we're in the square in this
weird regime where everybody here knows
that none of these are true so how I
want to push in a little bit on some
other things that we tell people that
also maybe aren't true kind of in this
talk just in case you you don't
believe me what are we okay first of all
what do I mean by machine learning I
mean something very narrow right for me
when I say machine learning yes I would
upset some of my colleagues nobly Mike
Jordan but I assess on my college might
say this is all machine learning is it's
just predict making predictions from
examples I have a set of something I
have a set of something else and I want
to find prediction functions that map X
to Y I know there's more than that but
this is the backbone this is why all of
you are here this is why they're
building our semester than this and so
the whole idea is that how do we
actually estimate these things we ask to
make them from data we collect as many
training data points as we can we ask
them ate them from data and then we just
hope that this works on other data a big
hope big hope is that we have a lot of
data if we collect enough of it we get
all edge cases we can drive our cars
whatever those cases are right and so
that's the notion of what machine
learning people mean by generalization I
actually think generalization is one of
the machine learning is full of words
that confuse the the listener they're
just designed to confuse you so
generalization when I say that to you
that means that you know you learn how
to throw a baseball and then you can
throw a softball that is not what we
mean in machine learning at all and
machine learning mean if you throw a
baseball you know how to throw a
baseball as long as this regulation
baseball made to regulation wait you're
gonna be able to throw that baseball and
that's not at all what would moral
people think right so the idea is that
you give me an examples from a
distribution I would like to find a good
prediction function on these examples I
have some loss function that I believe
is a reasonable thing that I would like
to minimize an expected value meaning
that if I have some new thing that comes
from this distributions I'd like to be
able to do well that's not known and so
what you do instead is you replace it
with the sample average and the
empirical risk and you minimize this and
like the only thing we're allowed to do
what's wrong the only thing we're to do
now is minimize this using one of two
algorithm and they're like three things
we can do we minimize it that way and
then of course our generalization error
is just the difference between these two
things and so the question is you know
if we can compute this one when is that
a good or bad proxy for the other one
right that's our whole that's what we
mean by
realization it's a very it's just a
badly named term but it's very
interesting couple problem and it's kind
of like the core problem in machine
learning right and the core theorem of
machine learning is that the the
population error that we really care
about is just equal to the training
error plus the generalization error
right sorry that's like the foundation
of ten thousand ten thousand papers
right we've all done that at one point
in our lives right so we can measure
this one and then we do a lot of
thinking about why this should be small
I mean this requires like the
associative property there's stuff to be
done here right I think we can equip a
little it about derive versus actually
Matic right so I think right so what can
we take away from this we know that if
you have a small training error that
means that the risk itself is just
you're really only in leveraging
generalization error right so if your
training error for example is zero
you're just hopefully know somehow that
the generalization error is small and
sorry and zero training error we know
does not imply overfitting even though
that's another thing that we do tend to
sometimes gets lost in the weeds like
for example the the paper I really like
which one test of time and we're at
knits last year by um Bruce K and Mbutu
right has this has this thing saying
that you shouldn't train you shouldn't
run an SGD too long because at some
point all of these terms should be one
over square root of n but we know that's
not really true right I mean just
because this is whatever squared event
doesn't mean this one is one over square
root of n and just cuz this is zero
doesn't mean this one's small so you
know we it's useful it's a useful way of
thinking about it but sometimes we over
fit to what kind of these papers say all
right so don't want to say it's not
always true but it's a useful way of
thinking about it another way that this
one ends up sometimes is presented this
is how I learned it not everybody
possess it this way is that you
decompose is this it's it's the same
same proof though it's you did you put
the error it's three parts right so
there you compare your error of your
estimator versus the error the best
thing in that in the class of stuff
you've been looking at right and then
you compare the error the best in the
class - like what the true prediction
function the best population risk
monument monitor is and then you are
stuck with some bias at the end
which is this is just the irreducible
error that you can never get away from
and to whichever one you like more I
don't care I like this one just because
it allows me to attack this most my
least favorite figure I'm kind of gonna
be like the core the core of the talk
today right so this is my least favorite
figure it's from hasty and tip shirani I
like those guys buns in this figure we
read way too much into this right so
somehow the idea here is that we have to
balance bias and variance in order to
get good model complexity again you can
do that you can do that but this is by
no means by knowing is the only way to
generalize and we know this okay I
learned this because of deep learning
and to be fair I learned this before and
had forgotten it and I'm gonna talk to
you about that in a second but I learned
it again recently because of deep
learning that you can just get make
these models gigantic and and they
generalize so in a very unpopular paper
that I know lots of people who are have
my back tear right now don't like sorry
maybe just one anyway so we read we read
a bunch of experiments on this if our 10
dataset everybody's favorite dataset
where we have chickens frogs deer in
trucks and you know you rut so this is a
10 class classification problem it's
relatively high dimensional has three
thousand dimensions because the pixels
50,000 data points and if you take you
know what we found is that you can
either get a loss to be nonzero here
this is the loss is the log loss which
is not the classification accuracy you
can work really hard to get this to get
your generalization error down and in
this case the test error or you could
just run it to zero essentially just
taking this configuration and turning
off all the regularization round to zero
and while you see a drop in accuracy you
don't see a gigantic drop so the test
error increases but only by about 5% and
moreover if you just pick a bigger model
now you're considerably better than the
original Alex net if you pick an even
bigger model you keep going down she
wants here I'm sure he tried something
even larger we just ran out of time so
right so somehow here that the the the
regularization parameters turned out to
be just knobs that you can tune in terms
of you could also tune architectures you
could do lots of things
and keep pushing this error down and
indeed we saw the same thing on image
net where here we have chicken frog
Deere and truck much more clear right I
think at that point anyway and so we
looked at an inception model inside
Google I really don't like this
experiment I just want to show it just
to kind of give evidence that this
happens and larger datasets the reason I
don't like this experiment is that
because of the way that these things
were trained Inc site Google at the time
we were able to run about six
experiments six runs I think have we
used I think one of the more valuable
things that's happened to the community
is this add-on benchmark and we just
used the DA benchmark we've been enabled
around hundreds of experiments much
better here but all we were able to do
here was toggle flags inside some Google
3 models and so in particular you know
in this case what we could do is we
could turn off the LT regularization and
we could turn off the the drop out sorry
the UM data augmentation and you could
still get perfect dieter palatial and
even note that the top five accuracy
here is only 19 point three sorry tight
error top tight five errors only ninety
point three you try to get to something
that has a 19 point three percent error
it's really hard so it's significantly
worse than what the inception model is
getting but again it's not it's not
catastrophic about this would have won
this would have beat Alex net the first
time around so still if it's good
accuracy yeah
let's ever talk like that regularization
before my control variance so what yeah
so okay there is talk of implicit
regularization I guess what I would say
is that we started to just look at more
models when we started to do is stop
looking at just this individual models
or for we just started download more
this actually became a big trend in the
research group um it's there's something
that Becca roll-off started kind of kind
of pushed us on this direction and the
mood became sitting here kind of really
pushed us even further in this context
it huh Baz an experimental resource so
you just get pull some some models and
then see what happens and a bunch of
things so this is the scatter pot I
don't really buy that parameters the
neural network is actually meaningful
but you can see that essentially as you
make the number of parameters bigger the
models continue to get bigger blue line
is just the minimum error and the red is
just a scatter plot isn't models
at a particular model size I'm just
taking the minimum error of the Reds
yeah I mean like I'm not saying that
they're all true I'm just saying you
could do a pull request over here I go
fine
I say I can call Fernando get him on
this one this is even better what you do
here is just remove models and so now
you see the trend this is there's no
Alex net or vgd on here they kind of
ruin that but they're just up here some
ways fundings like the Curt you really
care about this lower envelope but this
is the same thing kind of happens on
imagenet you just keep making them
bigger well you'll know he's like we
have log axis on the X and and and and
linear on the Y so semi-log this I
pulled from a paper by some Google folks
because only Google folks would think it
would be fun to train something with 600
billion parameters million million
million ok that's reasonable 600 billion
was stupid but six our million perfectly
reasonable anyway so that's that one
he's getting bigger
here's your visa this is from misha's
talk yesterday well I made it but it's
fine it's the same same plot right we
see the double descents this is now
we're random feature models where we
just keep adding random features and see
how the accuracy goes and even though it
does go up it kind of comes back down as
you make the models bigger and bigger
am i i'm just interpolating so this one
is just interpolate I'm not doing this
case is man we minimum euclidian arm
although although what's interesting is
that I like this plot better is that if
you don't do minimal Euclidean norm but
you just go use read regression so you
allow yourself a tunable parameter now
that dip goes away no it just gets
better
oh so I don't know all right so this is
not minimum nor mystique this is
regression and then that bump goes away
yeah you've picked the best Ridge you
pick the best Ridge it's not a constable
I picked the best one for each and
you're gonna see why in a second this is
the best one for each it's the only done
with a number of features give it like
for that the best value goes down every
number is so yes so sorry in this case
I'm not taking the best one from here
I'm not taking the best of these two it
is just if I tuned this what's the best
I can do just on this one fiber
here is a paper something I stole from
Peter this is from an inner UPS actually
was nipped at the time but nerves
tutorial from 20 years ago here he was
doing boosting some of us what do you
see here well I have first of all note
the semi-log axis there we go semi log X
on the you know that's pretty neat and
you add parameters I mean boosting right
you increase your model size with every
step and so now I have the models get
bigger and bigger and bigger and the
test error keeps going down I think the
the so that's that was interesting right
so that was small data machine learning
but I still seem to have a thing this is
another really interesting one which I
pulled from a C ACM article by Bell and
Koren describing how they won the
Netflix prize and they saw exam the same
thing that they have different kinds of
models but they kept making their models
larger again we have semi log X on the
routers linear in error and you see this
thing kind of continue to keep going
down to bigger and bigger you make your
model so I think there is something
interesting there so there you're seeing
two things one making the model really
huge doesn't doesn't you know it has a
ton of capacity maybe you're controlling
it with various kinds of regularization
of some form or another but oh it just
seems make it bigger worry about that
later
does seem to be a good take home and the
other thing is that you see significant
diminishing returns right I mean if you
have a log x axis I mean this doesn't
mean that eventually you have to give up
even Google eventually you have to give
up so I'm not sure that this is
necessary how to get a suit like that
that irreducible error we'd like to get
you
no no no no no it's not a typo not a
typo a hundred thousand million that's
like Carl Sagan it's a hundred thousand
million parameters that's a big deep I
didn't make this plot they don't get
their ice log these need different
things you have to read the caption
that's not here sorry I maybe should've
edited these things do not mean don't
they're in the caption whatever those
mean I don't know what those numbers are
these number factors are you sure paper
[Laughter]
anyway so we could look it up and think
see a cm it's cool they did a lot of
good work let's go back to this one so
look here's what I would like to say
like there are crazy diminishing returns
- it does seem making the model bare for
a fixed holdout set that we fix in time
for the history of the universe does
make that test error go down but that's
also not generalization error alright if
you do a holdout split or you take a
train set and you take a holdout set and
then you just fix that holdout set
forever maybe what's happening here is
you have this these giant models have
enough fluctuations in them that they
can you now over you could actually leak
a lot to the test set and over fit to
this one holdout set that you fixed
forever so this leads to a question this
leads to a question we're all spend most
of the rest of the time of the talk
there it's perfect I mean I know we have
planet I'm good so yeah that's the rest
of the talk so maybe maybe what's
happening here is you make these models
really big and that allows you to
overfit on this one holdout set and so
there's only one way to check right
which is make a new holdout set okay
there a better way I don't know but we'd
that's what we did that's what we did we
made a new holdout set let me explain
how so if here is progress on SIF r10
over time so if you just use raw pixels
and do linear classification you get
thirty seven percent accuracy
I just realized we've switched from
error to accuracy hopefully it will be
clear from context of the same accuracy
now we have 97.1% in 2017 and 2019 what
is it lou big-nose these numbers
ninety-nine point what nine point zero
so we got you know there's still time to
write more iclear papers everybody we've
got ten more ten more ticks so this is
like our deep revolution here all right
this is the deep revolution happened in
2012 and you know we just keep making
progress make them bigger get them more
capacity make these models really large
the shake-shake models are you.why
rednecks also or just ones right I try
to get them to fit brushes is this
overfitting right is this overfitting
right because this early part we can
match with shallow Methos yeah actually
you can get even get to like eighty I
can't remember the number but there's
there some work by chumki cada aleck
agrawal greg valiant and leigh song like
white 13 so if you just do random
features just you can get to about 85%
accuracy using just dumb random features
shallow stuff can get it was big so it's
also a large shallow model can get to
about 85 and so the question is are all
we're doing here is just overfitting to
the test set by graduate student design
so we're gonna check and we're gonna
check by building a new test set now
what does that mean so it turns out that
the syph are ten creation process is
super well documented and it was
documented by the folks at Toronto who
made it in the first place
and so there there is a lot of details
about how they did it and in particular
where they got their images to begin
with and that comes from one of my
favorite data sets ever it's called the
80 million tiny images the tiny images
data set and it's a was curated by
Antonio - Rob Rob Ferguson bill Freeman
and they made beautiful like scatter
plots like all the images on the
internet and these like mosaics and just
seeing like how everything varies it's
very cool kind of looking at what kind
of things are out there that you can get
to get off the internet in 2008 so the
reason why there were thumbnails is
because they wanted to make something
that you could store and then do all
sorts of visualization and studies with
so from these thumbnails they subsample
60,000 using a process that was very
well detailed supply well detailed with
human not experts but human laborers and
they tried to get down to these ten
classes so can we get iid resampling
well there are you know there's out of
80 million images we only took 60,000
out so the hope is maybe we could sample
some more maybe not even that many more
how many do we need to actually get
something that would believe so I think
Ludvig did his error bar calculation
that said mm that's what he wanted 2,000
new ones and so and work that I did not
want to get involved with Ludvig Becca
and VY salt labeled I say mostly just
Becca right this one for this one was
looting in Becca labeled tens of
thousands of images in in the tiny
images data set and we got a new test
set of size 2000
and again there find details about like
what counts as a boat what counts to the
car and this kind of thing we drive to
match as closely as possible so what did
we see okay so the first thing we see is
we take vgg 16 everyone's favorite
network all right I guess anyway this is
a big one and what we saw is a huge drop
in accuracy right there's an 8 percent
drop in accuracy from the first test set
to the second test set which is much
bigger than you would expect by a 1 over
root N and some some reasonable capacity
that's big mean this is we put a little
confidence interval about where we
should be this dashed line is the
reproducibility you'd hope that the
confidence interval would hit the dash
line that would mean okay there's you
know these we'd say hey we're not having
been overfitting at all well that's
great that's great so it's clear what's
gonna happen cuz right 85.3 was right in
the ballpark of what people had seen you
could do with just showering clearly
what's gonna happen let me just I don't
know if anybody's read this paper yeah
but clearly what I thought would happen
what I put my money on was that yeah now
the shallow learning stuff will just be
here and we'll just see that we'll just
get a saturation so we've just been
adapting and we'll just see a saturation
up here and everybody will be equal and
right and that was like this big drop
and so here here here's our random
features that's not what we saw at all
not what we saw at all I lost money
I didn't lose money because all
everybody else got the same it's good
there was no house in this case right
bigger drop 12% drop so that went from
eighty five point six to seventy three
point one bigger job present and the
shake-shake model only had a 4% drop
this one that had super-high Agra so we
saw exactly the opposite of what our
hypothesis said right our hypothesis
suggested that maybe the big models were
able to just fluctuate themselves to
overfit to there's one particular
holdout set and if we draw a new holdout
set we'll see some sign that they had
adapted to it but we saw the opposite in
fact the ones that have the better test
error on the original test set have a
better accuracy on the new testament
oh did you have the original weights for
these models or did you have to retrain
them we did well there was that we did
retraining in the paper but in this case
this was just original weights this is
some summary training but again this is
why github as an experimental resource
is so powerful people put post the
weights in the repos saves you tons of
time so it actually is the contrary it's
very you don't even need a GPU right
thank you you can just download stuff
that people already done change a
parameter here do some kind experiments
you already picked out like got a big
problem here right so there there was
clearly this is not an iid resampling
it's not ID resampling because that can
Ludvig or not we don't know who the
toronto folks were probably some paid
undergraduates and they're not that kind
of like who have never been to Toronto
right yes so there is a there is a yeah
so it's not perfectly ID right this is a
great question but we'll come back to it
let's come back
on the empirical training possibly yeah
but no you can't tell a difference if
you train a classifier do you sample
test what white features oh just
individual features to see if you see
significant things we didn't do we did
not do any of this yeah but let me keep
going well then they're not from the
same distribution right Marshall over it
yeah we would hope so right I mean I
that that you could probably check
because there were some sub selected to
begin with right
so if too many were sub-select 'add then
they're not going to be iid and that's
something I think we could probably the
dead part didn't vote human so that part
did not involve humans but not he's
asking is just that probably the only
thing that changed probably again being
generous to us the only thing that's
changing here is the labeling function
not that of the human the thing is
producing the why not the thing that's
producing the X actually sight under why
you only cycle
you just want to know if you could do
read you interleave the two test sets if
you or sorry if you can interleave some
of the stuff into the training data so
we're gonna be then the entire and
actually the fact that better models
have a smaller drop suggests that maybe
this boils down to the test and it could
be I mean what well so sorry what so
what were you what are you suggesting
can we just quit crossing it so this is
actually really important this is really
important the fact that you've already
moved on from the fact that there's no
adaptive overfitting is shocking look
there's no adaptive overfitting
we took this is rule one don't look at
the holdout set more than once that's
rule one we look at the holdout set
fifty thousand trillion times at Google
every day fifty thousand trillion times
and yet it doesn't matter the better you
do on this holdout set this one stupid
fixed holdout set like it doesn't matter
that I think really before we talking to
about why the drop happens just the fact
that we don't see adaptive overfitting
isn't it blew my mind I did not think
that would happen I did not think that
was
or whether you see the single noun to
productive or fitting into some others
and so those are two different things
which so far from your results in love
wait what does that mean might be your
video yeah I cut her with Zico there's
no adaptive or control and this gap is
only because of the difference in the
distribution yeah the thing is to be
fair gonna be hard to get it's gonna be
well I think so but right listen one
second
what is that I think it's gonna be hard
to tell from safar 10 and I think what's
interesting is if we go to this other
data set that's more interesting anyway
I mean maybe we can't a little bit but I
think it's much more competitive yeah
yeah I'm getting there
maybe I might be gay there we'll see how
a lot of people want to stay through
lunch yeah tell you it's not his hand up
for a second here go ahead what it's
gonna have a quick propose also epub
Bank I knows we can have like 50 km yeah
all these new data set and then test on
all superpower tested and I don't know
if we do get at leats I I don't think we
get too concerned about mm emerges and
some of 50 was a basically exposed so if
you wanted to get another 50,000 mm just
would actually be different
I think we could probably do more in
2000 but I'm not sure what the limit is
yeah yeah that's actually in the paper
you can see at the end but but also also
the thing is I only have two Becca Becca
and living now they have limited cycles
you know this is a problem it's a
problem it's a problem and certainly
certain and I lost both of them that's
really sad actually that's really sad
yet both well I know loot big sting
sorry good okay that was okay no first
thing we have to do though we did these
Becca she's graduated this year okay
also who cares about as if our time so
far ten is this fun little thing that we
all kind of like this we can train it
and it certainly it's interesting
because it's like the first non-trivial
thing we can get to but you know what
captured people's imagination was this
image net data set questions do we do
that one
now that's harder because that's bigger
there's more labels there's more and
even like even here like this 1.2
million
training images were not labeled in the
lab they were labeled using Mechanical
Turk that's opportunity right so now we
could try to reproduce this data set and
this procedure using Mechanical Turk
which makes it much more scalable and we
can make much larger who can do much
larger experiments so how do we get the
xiety resampling of image that in the
water but it's not as surprising as you
say given the fact that we can we can
drive particular models to zero laws
something which we thought was
impossible and that's okay this is like
the community drive in there
it's like community doing or repeating
on the test and it's kind of a same
effect
no I don't think so like why do it why
don't we see a plateau
anyway that's right that's right that's
why anyway
let's this is more interesting Misha the
zipper tempting is so boring that meets
let me show you this one this is much
more interesting much more interesting I
promise I promise much more interesting
as if you want we can go into some more
nitty-gritty with this one I have far
more that I'm gonna be able to get
through which is fine it's about no
equations I'm no proof assemble class
like this so this this is kind of the
interface that you would see if you were
a mechanical turk being paid to label
images on the internet which is
basically how all of our everything is
made to work now inside all the big tent
companies they hire people and have them
watch horrible disturbing content and
flag it for their their algorithms is
great wonderful world we live in
so hey so we have so here's our images
right these are supposed to be bow
everybody can read the top a bow is
actually is not quite clear a weapon for
shooting arrows composed of a curved
piece of resilient wood with a top cord
to propel the arrow and the task is
click on every single image that has a
boat that's what the Turker is asked to
do click on every single image that has
a bow so for example these three have
both these ones don't actually these
were three that were adversarially
placed in here to make sure that the
people that that the turgor z' weren't
cheating by the so what we were eight
what we did was we actually flag all of
these nuke
so we come in reproducing and
reproducing image that we tried to
reproduce the query that was used to
collect images reproduce the things that
were allowed like including the date
range from flickr reproduce the way that
these things were labeled and we also
through the old test set in here to see
how those were labeled by these Turner's
which is much much nicer than what we're
able to do with with safar tender and
what's interesting here is that there's
super high variability in what
everybody's like not everybody says the
same thing obviously there's gonna be
disagreement right there's one you have
this is site anybody who work in
crowdsourcing knows this right you have
the people who do these tasks see
through they work too quickly or there's
just new us right so for example
this is this bow was selected a hundred
percent of the time by every turn this
one was 70% of our heroine from brave I
mean there's a bow there it's a little
bit hard to see you on this blown off
screen right so there's a loss of reason
it's not Center frame so the lot of
reason to miss it
this one now becomes a metaphysical
conversation about what is the bow good
friend Conrad Curtin says yes so I mean
neuroscientist so you know I don't know
everybody has a good opinion about what
that is and this one's wrong and then
20% of the people the boat it's a boat
it's not the boat we want we want right
ok so I think that's that's our issue
right so this is not the boat we want
and so we actually had like the
histograms for every class for every
class thousand classes we had histograms
of the selection frequencies and so when
we actually sampled our new test set we
tried to match the statistics of the the
label from the original set with the new
set also the big back end vise all
looked at every single image and made
sure it was correct in the new test
which is clearly creating a distribution
shift yes Alex told me it's Berg told me
but I'm not anyway it's not true oh yeah
you could go look look that's actually
the other amazing thing about all these
data sets how many people who ever
looked at the images name isn't it
I mean you don't need to you just watch
the curve go down but like you know it's
like actually especially though it's
like we kind of have decoupled ourselves
from actually any of the domain
expertise it's actually quite
entertaining what you do
yes it's quite a JD what do you do I
grew up right ok so punch line right we
see exactly the same thing we see
exactly the same thing we saw in
separate n a bigger drop technically
speaking is the tempers dislike it 10
percent drop at the top here for the
best ones but we still see a positive
slope so the models that have that
models that fared better on the original
set fared better on the new set but a
little bit it's not for analysis it was
first two part 10 but we definitely see
a positive slope in our fit but we do
still see the significant drop
so what is how is the new legally we
need you said you also labeled the
ultimately just we labeled the old
imagenet just to match the selection
frequencies from our so okay there's was
there a distribution shift already you
are you already pointed out that Ludwig
and Becca are not the same and then we
matched their sampling frequencies but
you also in the process you also saying
we sampled from we have a bigger pool we
didn't have our new test set with a
bigger pool of images and we sampled
from that pool to match the statistics
of the old Tessa oh just the statistics
yes no no no not using in this
evaluation say there are no old images
in here really yeah yeah yes and there
isn't same neighborhood yeah you can
measure how will the old labels this
might labeling take those images on
those images take the predictor defined
by the old labels yeah
accuracy on old accuracy images it
doesn't write it has seven foundation
just old validation is yeah it's noisy
its noisy no man it's noisy it's still
noisy again so the orange right here
nothing too big nor think it's then but
even if it doesn't matter it says you're
taking the label that was as it appears
in the chain sent every image on these
the label yeah it was generated using
some procedure yeah measure of how well
those predictions predicted a pose that
was assigned to me for your process
that's not how these sets are built at
all hey Louie let me I got that I've got
the okay it's okay I got the forest but
I know I'm also used to this it's a
procedure it's a procedure so so it's
also true right that that none of
there's no these data sets are not made
by labeling images again like what
happened right you show people you you
query and then you test correctness as
to whether or not they go in or out it's
a weird it's a weird process the other
thing that's really interesting by the
way the other thing it's really
interesting we take for granted the
question you asked the Turkish is which
which of these images contains at least
one type of object Bo that is not the
classification problem that everybody is
now weightlifting against each other for
the question we have now is just label
the damn image it has one label and that
label somehow comes out and we know that
like why is this a book I mean this
contains a bow but this is the the I
forgot her name what's her name
she's from brave okay it's not Elsa
that's frozen I know that one yeah great
so again like I asked you what is that
image you it you could describe so much
it's Elsa in a forest with her bow on
the branch here anyway there's like I'm
sorry Meredith excuse me anyway right so
it's like a much more complicated thing
and what we evaluate is very different
let me do I I didn't make the original
image that day is that so I I just
illusion equals ask the question was we
asked exactly the same question that the
imagenet people asked I'm just saying
it's the exact same question
oh my god maybe you should redo it
$1,000
it's really expensive it's really
expensive it's so at anytime you want to
say you want more right I mean just note
that this is a very expensive project
and thank you to Microsoft for Darren's
leave funding part of the lately anyway
can I just let me just blaze for to cut
late so they run Mont I have to like two
more examples do you want I mean
everyone's goal oh yeah okay
okay here two things I do think and yeah
you could fight with me maybe try to
find more evidence that we do not see
adaptive overfitting or this is not
obvious but we do see significant
fragility from distribution shift and
the distribution shift is here is just
humans disagreeing with each other
barely I mean just so sorry Simon humans
disagreeing with each other it's just
that there were much chemikal Turkish in
2011 and now they're mechanical turkeys
and 2019 and that's different people
most likely I don't think people Turk
for that long
oh geez no no retraining no nothing is
just take the thing take the weights
don't have to retrain because otherwise
that would be really expensive again
unless they were tearing with the dawn
bench some of them are really slow you
know some of them come from Google so
they're really really slow and so you
have like these things that are huge but
yeah the trend is the trend is so the
question is can we find more evidence I
just want present more data and then
I'll stop go ahead
I know man well it's the small that it
feels like it's the small distribution
shift and just manifested in a huge
error so I guess the other way I'd say
that is small distribution shifts and
seem to propagate into large like
imagine what happens in reality right I
mean this is like one of these so then I
say I mean this is trying as hard as we
possibly could to match the statistics
maybe we could've tried harder it's it's
yeah it's a small distribution shifting
reduces the large error and we should be
worried about that I'm more worried
about that than the diminishing returns
reversing but what's also surprising
that in what flux you're just like you
would imagine that the fragility
increases as it were it doesn't right so
they clearly all we have to do is go
from 600 600 million parameters to 600
billion parameters and we'll be up on
the line and then it'll be fine right I
guess then we'll have cheese
self-driving and full self-driving will
happen once we get up there but um yeah
I don't know I mean I don't know I don't
know how to extrapolate this any further
because I we've already even even at
Google they've run out of resources
actually even iid know and actually I
think the test set okay validation set
commissioner and folded into the
training set and so on you can basically
the same actresses yeah evidence
video yeah you want lunch you don't see
plots 10:00 you want to see Plus man you
want to fight with him I have a date bar
in my back right so this is this is a
cool one same time this is a curated
data set for 2015 by the original image
net folks right here there was like
there were 4,000 videos but then they
just rendered them down as 1 million
JPEGs and then presented to you as JPEGs
and each of these corresponds to some
classes it's a 30-30 classes the subset
of imagenet so what we know exactly
where these images came and it's kind of
it was supposed to be for video but you
could just use this for detection and
classification and what we did is we
invented a metric that's fairly
reasonable metric which is you teach you
cheat each video as a set of similar
images and then for every frame you pick
a K and you look in the neighborhood of
that K and you see if you could find one
where you get a miss classification this
just allowed us to prune through that
data set pretty quickly so remember that
these are all mostly 30 frames per
second videos so 10 frames is about a
third of a second ok so so here's some
cool pictures you see these cotton
pickers on Twitter all the time where we
go from a domestic cat and within 10
frames it's called a monkey
oh yeah I think it's cuz now I see a
monkey this what I don't see it goes
from bird to domestic cat I guess that's
what is he eating
I don't know this one goes from turtle
to lizard this one goes from dog to
horse what's amazing it's easily these
images to you look the same I mean I
have to tell you to squint to see why
they're different right again within a
third of a second of each other and of
course Jason can't see you that's right
to Jason that jason has a good filter
that makes them all look to say they all
are cats and we made a lot of effort to
like make sure when you're going through
here that the kinds of things we were
pruning when we actually get to this
next plot were like deep so the ones we
saw before would look really similar
these look really different right these
are very different we prune those they
did not go into the data set when we
were doing curation so we did this again
we I didn't do this
Ludvig if I saw I saw Dave we
incorporeal Ike like we recruited people
from CMU for this I mean it's like a lot
of work to label and we see the exact
same plot man we see the exact same plot
so that you yeah again like just using
this metric you see exam this big shift
this again it's again it's a small
distribution ship is within four point
three frames this is 10 this is PM 10
this is in 0.3 seconds of each other you
see it's a small distribution shift and
again everything you don't see adaptive
overfitting you do see some sensitivity
to distribution shift let me skip this
go I'll talk about the end finally
kaggle two more things Kaggle CAG will
released a nice meta-analysis that were
metadata set of all their competitions
with a lot of information not all the
information we would have liked but a
lot of information everybody knows on
cavil you have a public and a private
leaderboard the nice thing is almost in
every competition here those are a ID
split from each other this is cool
because now what we should see is that
if you train the public leaderboard and
you train and you somehow evaluating the
on the private you should just see
clustering around the y equals x and
that's exactly what we see clustering
around y equals x and it's not just on
two it's on like B's how many do we do
look I forgot the number
117 I don't have all of them in here but
really key in this case because you have
iid splits you just see clustering
around the y equals x so now so again
evidence that distribution shift because
these are these are iid evidence here is
that the distribution shift is really
what's causing us to be ok I'll stop
there um oh sorry the most important
slide of course is that you because no
one day right the data set to make all
data sets and we see Leon Batu wrote
this beautiful oral history of the M
this data set and also managed to
reconstruct a bunch more examples and
it's very nice fun read and again we see
the distribution shift again between
these two tests we were doing accuracy
so it should be negative right yeah yeah
I didn't want to I just cut this out of
their paper I should already made it
that all right so I'll stop there it
sounds like we've seen this before we
know this we knew this was true in
boosting the interpolating training data
we knew that was fine and it did seem to
always make you like building bigger
models seem to have better test error
making your models big doesn't hurt but
definitely does seem to be some other
issues that are going to really be the
pressing ones that we need to deal with
moving forward I'm not sure Jonathan and
I will talk about how we teach this to
our undergrad machine learning class is
very gently I think so how but I do
think that for us the researchers and
and for anyone in industry the big
issues the bigger issues are this
distribution shift is a real dangerous
thing right if you're putting it in a
car or you're making health care
decisions and like that we I can show
you if you're interested afterwards I
could show you a paper which which
demonstrates that actually a lot of the
there's huge distribution shift effects
in medic with all of the radiology
there's a deep learning for radiology
huge things where you're basically
overfitting to the machine that took the
image so that's dangerous if that's a
life-and-death situation
we already know that Tesla cars kill
people what's amazing about Tesla cars
two people have died driving under
trucks with their autopilot on in
Florida and what's nice about that is
that machine learning generalization you
should never make the same
twice I showed you your corner case and
yet two years apart same errand same
accident so this is a real thing that's
something we have to think about but you
know I think that's also cool there are
no theorems in this talk hard to do it's
all there - right there were two
theorems in this talk we'll talk to
shout whether or not they actually
passed the test later all right with
that everybody should go get lunch thank
you
[Applause]